oradour sur glane nom qui résonne comme
un glas hier un village à 20 kilomètres
de limoges
aujourd'hui et pour toujours un des
hauts lieux de la cruauté hitlériennes
ici tout est mort une ville incendiés
fusillé torturé un désert et penser aux
cataclysmes une seule maison ressemble
encore à une maison
un village réduite à son cimetière d'où
les derniers vivent ne peuvent plus
s'arracher
c'était le 10 juin 1944 à deux heures de
l'après-midi les ss sont venus
ils ont rassemblé toute la population
sur cette place d'un côté les hommes de
l'autre les femmes et les enfants
les hommes ont les emmener dans des
granges et abattu et puis on a mis le
feu à leur cadart un des rescapés
miraculeux nous guide à travers ces
décombres atroce
les femmes et les enfants on les a
rassemblés dans l'église et on les ya
mitrailler et brûlé vif
même les pépés dans leur voiture
par cette fenêtre une femme a pu
s'enfuir une seule plus de 1000 morts
toute la population d'un village de
france a été tué soigneusement
méticuleusement